لم يتشابه البقر عليهم فقد عرفوا لونها
وصفتها واستول دوها واحضرت البقرات الحمر
تطبيقا لخرافه دينيه مقيته مصممه للعدوان
على مشاعر امه كامله يتحدث ناطق باسم
كتائب القسام عن امر سبقه اليه القائد
العام للقسام محمد الضيف خلال اعلان طوفان
الاقصى فما شان البقر هي بقره ورد ذكرها
في العهد القديم وفسرت باعتبارها شرطا
للتطهر والخلاص اخر الزمان وهذا يستوجب
لدى اليهود المتشددين اقامه الهيكل الثالث
المزعوم مكان المسجد الاقصى والبقره
الحمراء الصافيه ذات العامين والاوصاف
الاستثنائيه هي اداه التطهر لمن سيهدم
المسجد حين تذبح في جبل الزيتون وفق طقوس
معقده لانهم وفق اعتقادهم مدنس الان بما
يسمونه دنس الميت ولا حل لهم الا برماد
البقره الحمراء بحثوا سنوات دون جدوى حتى
وجدوا خمسا في تكساس الامريكيه ذكر انها
نتاج هندسه وراثيه وقد وصلت الى اسرائيل
قبل عام واربعه اشهر بدعم حكومي وتردد ان
موعد الذبح كان سيحين في اكتوبر الفائت
مما دفع المقاو الفلسطينيه لاستباق
الامر ويواجه الاقصى منذ احتلاله عام
7 انتهاكات مدفوعه بمزاعم دينيه لاقامه
هيكل لم يثبته تاريخ او اثر والاقصى
المبارك عند المسلمين جميعا هو في صداره
المواجهه خصوصا بعدما قويت شوكه الصهيونيه
الدينيه وبات صوتها اعلى في قياده اسرائيل
ويرى مراقبون ان وحشيه الحرب على غزه
تتغذى من التطرف المتدثر بالسياسه وقد سمع
العالم نتنياهو بدايه العدوان وهو يتحدث
عما دعاه تطبيق نبوءه اشعيا على الاشرار
ثم يسقط قتال العماليق في نصوصهم على
الفلسطينيين بما في ذلك من حث على القتل
والتنكيل واذ يرى كثر في ذلك التفافا على
ديناميه الصراع بوصف احتلالا ومقاومه فانه
يعيق واقعيا من جهه اسرائيل قيام دوله
فلسطينيه تكون عاصمتها القدس لتصادم
بعقائد تجعلها موقع الخلاص اليهودي بما
يحيل الى تناقض اسرائيل في تقديم نفسها
بنفسها في الهويه هي تداخل ملتبس بين
القومي والديني وفي قانونها وطن تاريخي
للامه اليهوديه لكنها تت غنى بنظام علماني
يبدو اقرب لما توصف بقشره هشه يندفع منها
تشدد يتماهى مع الاحتلال الغاصب لمقدسات
المسلمين والمسيحيين على هذه الارض
المحتله وفق القانون الدولي تتحشد معتقدات
وممالك غابره وتاريخ ماثل وفيها اليوم من
يدفعون عنها بارواحهم اجرام الاحتلال
باسلحتي واساطير
وابقار